hey guys no it's very interesting that a
lot of people out there believe it's
very offensive if you tell somebody hey
you're fat but why is it ok to tell
somebody hey you're very skinny you're
just missing bones man you need to eat
some more food why is that ok because
skinny guys also have feelings I mean
when I was younger I used to hate it
when somebody started to talk about how
skinny I was anyway for me over the
years I learned what type of foods to
eat to gain weight and also how to
maintain that way and that's what I'm
gonna share with you guys in this video
I'm gonna give you the best foods to ups
kidding guys gain weight so let's get to
it
I have a dream
[Music]
how babe mistakes but mistakes make you
strong alright guys I'm not gonna make
this very complicated so let's get right
into it let's start with the first one
healthy whole grain bread it's one of
the things that I love the most I eat it
almost every single day if you combine
it with with a good protein source like
eggs you'll get a well-balanced high
calorie meal that will help you to gain
weight but if you don't like bread then
try a whole wheat pasta which is just as
good nuts
yes nuts are the perfect healthy snack
to gain white nuts are very calorie
dense so just a handful of almonds for
example has over seven gram of protein
and 18 grams of healthy fats now just be
careful because eating a lot of nuts can
quickly add hundreds of calories red
meats now red means are one of the best
sources of creatine which also makes it
one of the best foods that will help you
to gain more muscle for example steak
contains around 3 grams of Leo sign per
170 grams now Leo sign is the amino acid
your body used to add new muscle tissue
lean and fatty meat will provide you
with good protein but fatty meat will
add more calories alright next one is
salmon and other oily fish it's a great
source of healthy omega-3 fat and
protein that will help you to gain
weight 470 grams filler you'll get over
300 calories around 4 grams of omega-3
fat and 34 grams of protein
[Music]
sweet potatoes sweet potatoes are a
healthy source of healthy carbs it fits
in with most meals and it is cheap just
one sweet potato gives you around 160
calories 37 grams of carbs and 4 grams
of protein whole milk and I know in
recent years a lot of people are very
negative towards Milton a lot of people
go on and drink it it is your choice
right but milk is great for gaining
weight so whether you drink it in glass
or you use it with your breakfast or
even better with a protein shake these
are on 100 calories in an 8 ounce glass
with 8 grams of protein 12 grams of
carbs and 3 grams of fat
next one is rice now rice should be one
of your go-to foods if you want to gain
weight especially brown rice because
it's a lot healthier for you than the
normal white rice because it's got more
protein and fiber and it also lowers
cholesterol one cup of brown rice will
give you around 216 calories 44 grams of
carbs and 3 and a half grams of fiber
avocado just like nuts avocados gives
you great quality healthy fat and it
goes very well with sandwiches or salads
one medium avocado gives you around 450
calories 13 grams of carbs to none grams
of fat and 3 grams of protein eggs I eat
eggs almost every single day because
it's so good for you in so many
different ways that you're not even
aware of Dec protein is a complete
protein that contains all the essential
amino acids for muscle repair and
recovery all right next one
Kanoa now most of you guys that's been
working out for a few years all that
experience probably already know the
benefits of canola because this grain is
a great source of protein because it has
all nine of the essential amino acids
your body needs to help muscle growth
now just a bonus tip apart from eating
all of these food you also need to start
eating a lot more food than your usual
the team if you want to have some better
results in gaining weight it doesn't
matter if you think you eat a lot you
need to eat a lot more calories than
what you burn in a day I feel like the
video give a thumbs up subscribe and
Google toxin Cheers
[Music]